so this is the second annual just 100
it's our list of the 100 companies that
are doing right by America how are they
doing in terms of work or treatment are
they treating their customers well this
is a big one this year privacy is a huge
issue we also look at how well do they
treat the environment what's their
record on human rights issues around the
world and the theme that kind of emerged
this year was one of self-regulation we
are finding that some of the best
companies in America are actually
stepping in and putting their own sorts
of regulations out there the government
isn't telling them to do this but the
market is their investors are their
customers are so for instance Microsoft
they're the number one company on the
list they score very well across all the
metrics we looked at they have an
internal carbon tax the CFO literally
taxes the different Microsoft business
lines based on their carbon output and
based on that carbon output than the
businesses up to pay attacks they're
doing it because it's good for the
environment and ultimately it's good for
business we sent out our tech reporter
Alex Conrad to Seattle and this is what
he told us about his view on how
Microsoft behaves it was really
interesting to see everything firsthand
we did a field trip to this industrial
neighborhood where you know this
experimental data center using fuel
cells was being tested there's no
Microsoft signage it's this dingy Street
with an HVAC you know air conditioning
company in front and then we walked
through a basketball court of this HVAC
company which is a Microsoft Partner and
get to this kind of nondescript building
and walk in and all of a sudden you see
this bright white kind of Spacey racks
of servers with these big grey boxes on
top and those boxes were fuel cells they
can use the fuel cell on top of the
server rack to power all of the data
centers operations you don't need the
transistors the substation think all
those electrical cables all of that
takes a lot of energy and a lot of cost
and so what Microsoft's doing is
basically cutting out all that middle
stuff and just having these fuel cells
right there fuel cells are too expensive
today for a lot of commercial use but
Microsoft hopes that if they can prove
this demand and build out these big data
centers using fuel cells they can drive
down the prices and make this some
more eco-friendly and cost friendly
solution and I think that speaks to sort
of the cool thing that Microsoft is
doing that I saw there which is a lot of
conscious environmental efforts that
also impact their bottom line here's
what CEO Satya Nadella had to tell us
himself environmental thing has always
been a priority but now it's sort of as
builders of big data centers it's a very
core priority for us we are going to
basically be carbon neutral in all of
our energy consumption so I would say
it's a much more of an existential
priority for us because you got to take
where the world is what are some of the
challenges of the world and then figure
out is your business interest really
helping the world solve some of its
pressing challenges if not then we have
a problem so where does all this good
corporate behavior leave us I genuinely
don't know it kind of gets back to the
question I asked myself a lot through
this reporting process which is how much
of a difference are all of these
companies making as an investor it
leaves you in a position to make more
money if you want to invest in companies
that are doing well for the world but
just 100 returned 7.5% over an almost
year period compared to the S&P 500's
three point six percent and Microsoft
over that period returned almost 30% I
think the investment case actually also
expands your options as a consumer Tom's
and Patagonia are very famous examples
of companies that have a clear social
mission and that are very popular
especially with millennial consumers
because increasingly companies are
communicating the ways in which they're
trying to be good to the world
[Music]